Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Ben bugün dünyanın en güzel ya da dünyanın
en bedbaht hikâyesini anlatacağım.
Nereden bakarsak bakalım
değişecek belki...
İnsanı anlatmaya çalışacağım.
Sanki biri onu anlatmayı becerebilmiş gibi
ben deneyeceğim ama...
Zaman zaman böyle gündelik hayatımda
çok kullandığım bir sözdür.
Özellikle böyle çok zorda kaldığımda,
çok canım sıkıldığında
böyle güzel latince bir söz öbeği vardır.
Der ki; 'Homo non intelligendo fit omnia’
yani insan, ne olduğunu anlamadan
insan olmuştur.
Ve söz öbeği şöyle devam eder.
Bir nevi dünyadaki tüm hikâyelerin
insanın asli vatanına dönüşüne
dair olduğunu söylermiş ve eklermiş;
dünyanın bu lekeli hâliyle tüm dünya
sadece ve sadece merhamet
yasalarıyla ayakta durmaktadır.
Bence çok derin bir felsefe etrafımıza
bakıyoruz, gerçekten bu kadar kötülükle,
şiddet, katliam, kıyım,
savaşlar, tecessüs, zan, iftira,
ganimet kültürü bütün dünyayı
bu kadar sarmışken
tüm bu kötülükler zaman zaman
herhâlde hepimizin aklına geliyor.
Dünya nasıl bu kadar kötülükle
ayakta kalabiliyor diye.
Bu dünyanın yaşadığı şeyin ben bir
organik kriz olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Bir nevi aslında dünya,
bir beka problemi ile karşı karşıya bence.
Çünkü tüm dünyada asabi dediğimiz şey
aslında insanların birbiri arasında
olan bağı çok ciddi anlamda
çökmüş durumda.
Bu ilk krizi değil yalnız dünyanın.
Dünya dediğimiz zaman biz onunla her zaman
yaşlı gezegenemiz diye ifade ederiz.
Bugün evrenin yaşının astrofizikçiler
13,7 milyar yıl olarak hesaplıyor.
Bunun 4,5 milyar yılında gezegenimizin de
içinde bulunduğu Dünya var.
4,2 milyar yılında canlılık var.
İnsanın Dünya’da misafirliği ise
her ne kadar birtakım tartışmalar
rakamla ilgili olsa bile paleontologlar
15 milyon yıl diyor.
Biyologlar 5 milyon yıl diyor.
7 milyon yılda çok şükür ki
uzlaşmış durumdalar.
Bize çok yakın iskelet ve kas sistemi
olarak bize çok yakın olan insan ise
onun izini biz 350 bin yıl öncesine
kadar sürebiliyoruz.
Daha 6 ay önce dünyanın bu konuda çok
itibarlı dergilerinden birinden biridir;
Nature Sciences’ da
yayınlanan bir makalede
Fas’ta yapılan kazılarda biz
350 bin yıl öncesine gidebildik.
Bir taraftan insan türüne ilişkin aslında
şaşırtıcı ve çok olumlu
birtakım durumlar da var.
Şöyle düşünün 350 bin yıl önce Dünya’ya
katkısı bilmiyorum bir iguana veya
bir kaplumbağadan daha fazla olmayan
ve çer çöple beslenen bir insan türü
bugün medeniyetler geliştiriyor.
Şehirler kuruyor.
Adalet, düzen teşkil ediyor.
Hiper yel kentlerde yaşıyor.
Yapay zekâ gibi unsurlarla birlikteyiz.
Tüm uzay yolu daha kat etmedi.
Peki burada çok önemli
iki tane soru var bence.
Bu soruyu soracağım.
Bu sorudan sonrada onun üzerine öneriler
yapmaya çalışacağım.
İnsan nasıl oldu da diğer türlerden bu
kadar büyük bir ayrım gösterebildi
ve büyük bir sıçrama gerçekleştirebildi?
Birinci sorum bu.
Peki bu sıçrama ile birlikte
yarattığı bütün bu teknoloji,
bütün bu akıllı tasarımlar,
nasıl beraberinde
bu kadar kötülüğü getirdi?
Sorusunun cevabını
vermeye çalışacağım.
Şimdi burada gerçekten insanların
kökenine ilişkin çok kozmik bir soru
ve bunun cevabı çok kolay değil ama
olabildiğince basitleştirmeye çalışacağım.
Şöyle söyleyeyim size bütün bunların
müsebbipi, sorumlusu şudur...
Eller...
Eller ve ellere bağlı olarak aslında
insanların imal yeteneği.
Bakın çok enteresan buna isterseniz
hayat müjdesi deyin, isterseniz doğanın,
tabiatın, erdemin, hakikatin,
Tanrı’ nın ya da yaradanın
yaratma biçimi deyin.
Hangi pencereden bakarsanız bakın eller
ve onun çerçevesinde gelişen imal yeteneği
hiç sebepsiz değil.
İnsan varlığını bir düşünün büyüklük
olarak düşünün, hız olarak düşünün,
kendisine özel hiçbir yeteneği olmayan
bir tür gibi görünüyor.
Av ve avcısını gördüğünü düşündüğünüz
zaman, onlarla karşılaştırdığınız zaman
hızlı değiliz, büyük değiliz, yırtıcı
değiliz ve bukalemun gibi saklanma
kamufle olma özelliğimiz yok...
Hayatta nasıl kalabilirdik?
Diye soru sorduğunuz da aslında hayatta
ellerimizi kullanarak kalabilirdik.
Ve insanoğlu bunu yaptı.
Ellerini kullanabilmek için ayağa kalktı.
Ayağa kalktığında başka bir
tezahür gerçekleşti
ve insanın leğen kemiği
birbirine yaklaşmaya başladı.
Yaklaşmak zorunda kaldı
ayakta kalabilmek için.
Leğen kemikleri birbirine yaklaştıkları
zaman doğum kanalı daraldı.
Doğum kanalı daraldığı zaman işte orada
mucizevi bir şey oldu:
İnsan türü, diğer bütün memelilerle
karşılaştırdığımızda
tam ve hazır beyinle doğmayan tek türdür.
Aslında yüksek primatlarda buna yakın
birtakım özellikler var
ama hiçbirisi insan kadar değil.
İnsan beyni gelişmeye matuf olarak büyür.
Anne karnında başlayan beyindeki
büyük gelişme özellikle insan ömrünün
ilk iki yılında korkunç bir hızla
beyindeki sinir hücreleri dediğimiz
hücrelerin kendisi arasında kurduğu
etkileşimle korkunç bir konnekton diyoruz,
sinir ağları haritaları,
korkunç bir hızla büyür ve bu yaşam boyu
süren bir gelişmeyi örnekler.
Başka hiçbir türde böyle bir şey yok.
Hayvanları düşünün,
diğer memelileri düşünün,
hazır ve dolu bir beyinle doğarlar.
O yüzden çok kısa sürede gelişirler,
çok kısa sürede temel ihtiyaçları
yani üreme, hayatta kalma, kendini koruma
fonksiyonundan bahsediyorum
ve aynı zamanda iletişim gibi
birtakım unsurları
çok kısa sürede yerine
getirmeye başlarlar.
İnsan türü ise öyle değildir.
Çok uzun süre bakıma muhtacız,
hâlâ çok zayıfız.
Fakat biz de aynı aynen hayvanlar gibi
aslında biz onlara içgüdü diyoruz.
Binlerce yıllık, milyonlarca yıllık
kalıtım yoluyla birbirine aktardıkları
temel bir davranış, duygu
ve eylem stratejisi vardır.
İşte içgüdü dediğimiz şey.
İçgüdü insanlarda var.
Ama insanlarda içgüdünün üstünde
başka bir projeleme stratejisi var.
İnsanlar beyinlerindeki bu hiç bitmeyen
gelişme ve sürekli olarak
öğrenme süreci ile biz zaten
beyni tanımlarken
evrenin en karmaşık nesnesi deriz
ve temel fonksiyonu hayatta kalmaktır,
bunu da öğrenerek yapar.
Dolayısıyla öğrenme hiç bitmez.
Sizde burada bugün
sabahtan beri yapılan konuşmalarla
yeni bilgilerle karşılaşıyorsunuz
ve beyninizin herkesin beyninin yapısal
ve kimyasal olarak değiştiğini
size garanti edebilirim.
Çünkü tüm hayat boyunca
bu şekilde ilerliyoruz.
Bu ek projeleme sistemi dediğim şey şu;
izle, öğren, kullan, geliştir, öğret,
değiştir, uyum sağla,
gerekiyorsa tekrar değiştir.
Biz hayat boyu aslında böyle bir
izlek içerisinde ilerliyoruz.
Bu insanın yerlerin, göklerin, doğanın
efendisi olmasının, besin zincirinin
en üst basamağı olmasının
bir numaralı nedenidir.
Sadece burada bitmiyor ama
bizde şuurlu beyin dediğimiz.
İşte neokorteks, prefrontal korteks,
orbitofrontal korteks diye adlandırdığımız
şuurlu beyin mekanizması
sadece insanlarda var.
Bu kadar gelişmiş olarak
Ve bu sayede biz zihin, gerçeklik, düşünce
gibi eylemleri gerçekleştirebiliyoruz.
Aynı zamanda biraz önce bahsettiğim
o konnektonlar,
yani birbirine bağlı
o sinir hücreleri haritası bağları
korkunç bir hızla biz
ona nöroesneklik diyoruz.
İnsanı her defasında her saniye her yeni
öğrenme pratiği ile değiştiriyor.
Bir de bunun üzerine insan kendi ürettiği
teknolojinin bir uzantısı hâline gelerek
kendi ürettiği teknolojiden de
etkilenmeye başladığı an
ortaya zaten bütün
bu yapabildiklerimiz anlamında
yüksek bir kapasite ortaya çıkıyor.
Peki biz bunu yapabiliyoruz o zaman
ikinci soruya geliyorum.
Bunları yapabiliyorken bütün
bu beraberinde getirdikleri
kötülüklerin sebebi ne?
Çok enteresan bir şekilde
yine aynı şey, yine ellerimiz.
Her şey burada başlıyor.
İnsanın imal yeteneği aynı zamanda ben
insanın evrendeki yolculuğuna,
insanın hadsizliğinin yolculuğu derim.
Bence çok güzel bir
felsefi bir yaklaşımdır.
İmal yeteneği aynı zamanda beraberinde
büyük bir hadsizliği getiriyor.
Bakın, insan imal yeteneği sayesinde
ilk önce kendi biyolojisini bozuyor.
Daha sonra doğayı ve
bütün ekosistemi altüst ediyor.
En basitinden bir örnek vereyim.
Şekeri düşünün, şeker doğada
çok zor bulunan bir maddedir.
Dünyada her şey,
organik ihtiyaçlar temelinde gelişir.
Biz dünyayı kendi hâlinde bıraksak
zaten dünya muhteşem bir yer olurdu.
Muhtemelen insansız bir dünya
tasavvur edin.
Hâlâ cennet bahçesi olabilirdi.
Organik ihtiyaçlar dünyanın
akıllı tasarımıyla alakalıdır.
Şeker niye az bulunur?
Çünkü şekere az ihtiyaç vardır.
Fakat biz imal yeteneğimiz ile birlikte
konsantre edilmiş kaliteli şekeri
1 TL’lik nuga barlarda,
köşedeki markette satabildiğimiz için,
üretebildiğimiz için tüketebiliyoruz.
Ve beraberinde pek çok
rahatsızlık karşımıza çıkıyor.
Ya da insanın ve aslında tüm canlıların
temel üreme sistemi olan
temel sistemlerinden olan
üremeyi düşünün...
Sırf türün devamı için kendisini
parça parça dişisine feda eden
örümcek türleri var.
Sırf türünün devamı için.
Biz oysa ki imal yeteneğimiz
konusu ile birlikte
pornografi diye bir şey geliştiriyoruz.
İnternette arama motoruna iki tane tık tık
yapıp istediğimiz çok hızlı
hijyen cinselliğe ulaşabiliyoruz.
Bu da beraberinde pek çok
problemi getirebiliyor.
Üreme problemleri,
toplumsal şiddetin artması
ve aile içerisindeki sorunlar gibi...
Her şeyin sorumlusu insanın imal yeteneği
aynı zamanda iyi ve kötü şeylerin...
Sadece burada bitmiyor.
Sadece sizi düşündürmeye çalışacağım.
İnsanın aynı zamanda türünün önemi
konusunda da büyük bir hadsizliği var.
Birleşmiş Milletler Çevre Programı bugün
dünyada sekiz milyon yedi yüz bin
türün varlığından söz ediyor.
Bilim insanları bunları kategorize etmiş
durumda, sekiz milyon yedi yüz bin tür.
Dahası da var;
gelecekte bulunmayı bekleyen yaklaşık
yüz milyon türden bahsediyoruz.
Bugünkü teknolojimizle belki bu bin yıl
alacak ama yüz milyon tür.
İnsan türü sadece bunlardan bir tanesi...
O zaman niye kendimizi
bu kadar abartıyoruz?
Niye kendimizi bu kadar aşırılaştırıyoruz?
Amerikalıların bir söylemi vardır
‘Overrated’ diye.
Niye böyleyiz?
Çünkü ilahiyattan,
teolojiden yola çıkarsak
insanın eşref-i mahlukat
ya da ahsen-i takvimi olması
insanın birtakım kapasiteleri ile alakalı;
idrak, tefekkür, tevekkül...
İnsan bunları kullandığı zaman bunları
kullanma kapasitesine sahip olduğu zaman
eşref-i mahlukattır.
Ya da letafet, feraset, zarafet...
İnsan bunları kullanabildiği zaman
şuur, duygu, ahlak ve erdemle birlikte
bu özelliklerini kullanabildiği
zaman ahsen-i takvimdir.
Bunları kullanmadığı zaman ortaya
maalesef bambaşka kirli bir yığın çıkıyor.
Üçüncü mesele zaman meselesi...
Bakın birtakım rakamlardan bahsettim.
Dünya’ nın dört buçuk milyar yıllık
tarihinden bahsettim.
Dört buçuk milyar yıl...
Hadi bir alegori yapalım.
Bu da insanların yeteneklerinden biridir.
Dört buçuk milyar yılı
bir gün olarak düşünelim.
Bu durumda Dünya’nın da
saat 24’te yaratıldığını düşünelim.
Dünya 24’te yaratıldığında sabahleyin
saat 05.00'da canlılık başlayacak,
akşamleyin, geceleyin saat 23.00'da
dinazorlar var olacak
ve 23.40'da yok olacaklar...
İnsanın Dünya’daki misafirliğine yedi
milyonluk tarihine baktığımızda
saat 23.55'te insan oluşacak,
üç yüz elli bin yıllık modern
insan formuna baktığımızda
23.59'un son saniyesinde insan olacak.
Şu an çok abarttığımız Sanayi Devrimi,
otomasyon, yapay zekâ
ve bütün diğer teknolojilerin,
yaklaşık altmış yıllık hatta üç yüz yıllık
Sanayi Devrimi’nden aldığım tarihini
düşüdüğümüzde saniyenin sadece
%1’ ini kapsayacak.
O zaman yine aynı hadsizlikle
karşı karşıyayız.
Zaman içerisinde Divan Edebiyatı’ ndaki
çok güzel bir tabirdir o;
"zerre-i miskal kadar"
kainattaki bir toz tanesi kadar
yer işgal ediyorken...
Dünya’nın bundan sonraki bin yılına,
yüz milyon yılına ya da milyar yılına
etki edecek kararları bugünden
nasıl alıyoruz?
Alın size bir başka hadsizlik meselesi.
Peki bunların çözümü mümkün olabilir mi?
Gerçekten insanlar yeni bir
saadet devresine ulaşabilir mi?
Yoksa gerçekten Mars’ taki
koloniler peşinde koşmalı mıyız?
Bu gerekli mi?
İnsanın bu yüksek kapasitesi aslında
bize tarihin çeşitli zamanlarında
çok güzel işaretler veriyor.
Kendi kültürümüzden de veriyor.
Ben her zaman çok önemserim
ve çok üzerinde dururum.
Bu coğrafya çok büyük
bilim adamları yetiştirdi.
Farabi’sinden Gazali’sinden tutun,
İbn-i Sina’sına
önemli düşünür adamlarından
Mevlana’ya Yunus Emre’ye bakın.
İbn-i Sina bugün modern tıbbın
kurucularından biri olarak kabul ediliyor.
Dünya çapında bir
bilim adamından bahsediyoruz.
İşe nereden başlıyor biliyor musunuz?
İyilik ve kötülük kavramından başlıyor.
Bu konferanstan sonra bir ara
zamanınız olduğunda İbn-i Sina’nın
uçan adam metaforuna
bir dikkat etmenizi rica ediyorum.
Kötülük dediğimiz şey evet
iyiliğin yoksulluğu durumudur.
Ama kötülükle ilgili
binlerce tanım yapsak bile
en güzel en kısa yolu
kötülük tanımı şudur;
ötekini yok saymak.
İnsanın ötekini yok saymamak için
kendi varlığından haberdar olması gerekir.
İbn-i Sina da bunun peşinde.
Zaten metafizikten bilime giden
bir yoldan bahsediyoruz.
İbn-i Sina’nın uçan adam metaforunda
gözleri bağlı, kulakları duymayan,
vücudundaki hiçbir nokta
birbirine temas etmeyen,
göksel bir varlıktan söz eder.
Bu varlığın kendisidir.
Kendi varlığının haberindedir.
Fakat cismi ile hiç ilgilenmez.
Fakat bu varlık bir taraftan
egoyu sıfırlama yolculuğu,
bir taraftan nefs, bir taraftan insanın
o bütün saydığım o feraset,
letafet ve zarafeti peşindedir.
Çünkü insan ancak bu şekilde
saadete ulaşabilecek bir varlıktır.
Her ne kadar kişisel gelişim öğretilerinde
ruh, zihin ve beden gibi öğretiler
çok indirgenerek
değersizleştirilmiş olsa bile
insanın dünyadaki yolculuğu bu üçünün
bütünselliğinin yolculuğudur.
Çünkü diğer türlü elinizde ulaştığınız
hiçbir teknolojinin, hiçbir bilimin
hiçbir faydası kalmaz.
Bakın modernizm süreci aslında
çok iyi amaçlarla yola çıkıldı.
Sanatta, mimaride, kültürde,
her türlü teknolojide
en mükemmeli yaratmak için
başlayan bir süreçti modernizm.
Nasıl bitti?
İkinci Dünya Savaşı ve ardından
Vietnam’la bitti.
Biz bilim aracı ile
daha mükemmel silahlar yaptık.
Çünkü bu üçünün birlikteliği
söz konusu değildi.
Bizim ilk önce inançla, sezgisellikle
bilimi birleştirmemiz gerekiyor.
Bunlar birbirini dışlayan kavramlar değil.
Yani bilim demek Tanrı’yı dışlamak değil.
Bilim, Tanrı’yı ve dinleri dışlamaz.
Bilimin başka bir metodolojisi vardır.
Gerçek bilimden bahsediyorum.
Sahte bilimden değil.
Başka bir metodolojisi vardır.
Bilim sadece görülebilen
ve algılanabilenle ilgilenir.
Ve bilim her daim tüm gelişimlere kapısı
açık olan ve kendi metodolojisi
çerçevesinde, içerisinde aklı hikmet veya
tedrici tekamül
dediğimiz şeyi de barındırabilir.
Bu insanın kendi duygusu ile
ilgili bir durumdur.
Saydığım Farabiler, İbn-i Sinalar,
Gazaliler; Antik Yunan'dan itibaren
inançla bilimi birleştiren birçok
bilim adamı da aslında bunu yapmıştır.
Bakın düşünüyorum.
Hubert Reeves vardır.
Bence bir astrofizikçi, Kanadalı,
dünya çapında bir isim.
Hubert Reeves’ e sorarlar;
‘Tanrı, yaradan, doğa, erdem veya
hakikat adına ne derseniz deyin,
bilinçli tasarım gerçekleştirseydi
nasıl bir şey gerçekleştirirdi?’
diye sorar.
Hubert Reeves’ in cevabı şu olur;
tam da şu an yaptığını yapardı.
Dolasıyla her birimiz ilk önce
kendi hayat yolculuğunda
çünkü bu kollektif bir biçim alacak.
Mükemmel olmadığımızın
farkına varmamız gerekiyor.
Ve hiçbirimiz mükemmel değiliz.
Bizden önce cansızlık dönemi vardı.
Mikro organizmalar geldi.
Ardından dinozorlar ve buzul çağ,
ardından insan şu an yapay zekâ
ve yüksek teknoloji dönemi yaşıyoruz.
Dikkat edin türler geliyor gidiyor.
Türler yok oluyor.
Biri geliyor biri gidiyor.
Acaba bu saydığım Tanrı, doğa, erdem
veya hakikat sürekli birtakım türleri
tarih dışına iterek akıllı mükemmel
tasarıma mı ulaşmaya çalışıyor?
Biz ise maalesef;
‘Hilmi Cem mi daha delikanlı?
Turabi mi daha adam?
Beşiktaş, Fenerbahçe,
Galatasaray mı daha büyük?’
tartışmaları arasında ezilip giderken
insanı insan yapan
tüm üstün kapasite
özelliklerine uzak kalarak
aslında eşref-i kamil ve eşref-i mahlukat
veya ahsen-i takvim olma
özelliğinden uzak duruyoruz.
Bu konudaki önerim şu olacak;
sinir bilim dalı alanında pek çok
gelişmeye matuf olan var.
Çok çalışıyoruz.
Çok daha ilerlesin diye ama
hiç red edemediğimiz bir tane durum var.
Onu size tekrarlayacağım;
"Kullanılmayan beyin geri alınır."
Bu net.
Onu kullanmamız gerekiyor.
Onu kullanırken de önemli bir özellik
aslında farkındalık.
Latince bir sözle başladım,
İngilizce bir sözle bitireyim.
Bilgi felsefesi için çok önemlidir.
Der ki; "Knowledge comes
but wisdom lingers."
yani; "Bilgi koşarak gelir,
aklı hikmet ise emekleyerek gelir."
Önemli olan bunun farkında olmak.
Çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkışlar)